[Musique]
en Tunisie le président bourgiba déchu
du pouvoir pour raison de santé annonce
son premier ministre monsieur Benali qui
le remplace à la tête de l'État 70e
anniversaire de la révolution
bolchevique défilité défilé militaire
sur la Place Rouge Gorbatchev au centre
de la
tribune super le compte en demi-finale
de l'Open de Tennis de Paris il a battu
pas de cache et rencontre cet après-midi
team
Mayotte une journée supplémentaire de
détention pour Marcel carton Marcel
fontaine Jean-Paul
Koffman Jean-Louis Normandin d'Antenne 2
et Roger haw les autages français au
Liban n'ont toujours pas été libérés
madame monsieur bonjour Depuis ce matin
le président Habib bourgiba n'est plus
chef de l'État tunisien il a été
remplacé par son premier ministre
monsieur Benali on ne peut pas à
proprement parler parler de coup de
force ou de coup d'état puisque pour
écarter le président bourgiba du pouvoir
monsieur Benali s'est appuyé sur un
article de la Constitution tunisienne
qui permet en cas d'incapacité physique
de déposer le chef de l'État et l'on
sait que monsieur bourgiba qui est âgé
de 84 ans est malade ce qui ne signifie
pas pour autant qu'il avait l'intention
de se retirer
apparemment tout s'est passé dans le
calme jusqu'à présent du moins monsieur
ben al était entré en fonction il y a à
peine plus d'un mois le 2 octobre
dernier exactement pierre
serra le dernier geste officiel du
combattant suprême le président Habib
bourgiba aura été de nommer son 5e
Premier ministre depuis l'indépendance
et pour la première fois un militaire le
général abiddin Ben Ali c'était le 2
octobre dernier Abidin Ben Ali devenait
de ce fait constitutionnellement le
dauphin de celui qui avait été élu
président àe de la Tunisie cette nuit
faisant jouer l'article 57 de la
Constitution qui prévoit l'incapacité
pour le chef de l'État d'exercer ses
fonctions et sur la base de rapport
médical habidin Benali a déposé le
président bourgiba et a pris le pouvoir
devenant ainsi lui-même président de la
République chef des armées sans avoir à
procéder à des élections alors quelques
heures à peine après avoir pris le
pouvoir monsieur benalii nouveau
président de la République Tunisienne
donc a nommé son remplaçant au poste de
Premier ministre l'ex-ministre des
Affaires sociales monsieur Eddie
bacouche le gouvernement pour l'instant
subit peu de modifications à Tunis la
capitale ce matin tout paraît calme même
si quelques personnalités ont été mises
en résidence surveillée confirmation
tout de suite avec la correspondante de
l'agence France Presse Mouna Naba zinel
Abidin Ben Ali aura été le seul à oser
constater que bourgiba était vieux
malade incapable de gouverner et
d'entirer les conséquences conformé à la
constitution cité entraîne vacances de
pouvoir et c'est le premier ministre qui
prend les rêves tambour Battan le
nouveau président a remplacé les
ministres jugés les plus intrigants il a
annoncé un projet de révision de la
Constitution une nouvelle loi sur les
partis une autre sur la presse une
participation plus active du peuple
tunisien à la vie politique en somme une
bouffée d'air que des Tunisiens
stupéfait mais heureux ont accueilli
dans la plus grande
sérénité alors un premier commentaire
tout de suite avec Éric roulau et Pierre
serra Éric roulau qui était encore
récemment ambassadeur de France à Tunis
jusqu'à l'année dernière Éric Roulot
vous êtes actuellement ambassadeur
itinérant et c'est à titre personnel que
vous êtes venu ici sur ce plateau pour
nous parler de la situation en Tunisie
alors tout d'abord première question
tout simple est-ce que vous vous êtes
surpris non pas du tout pas du tout
avant même que je pose les pieds en
Tunisie j'ai eu le sentiment lors de ma
nomination que le président mitteran et
le gouvernement se préoccuper déjà de
l'évolution des choses en Tunisie et
c'était temps c'était l'été 85 vous
voyez ça ça remonte assez loin et peu
après mon arrivée j'ai j'ai pu constater
qu'effectivement leur craintte étaient
fondées parce que d'une part le
président bourgiba et ça c'était un
secret de
polichinal n'était plus déjà dans dans
la possibilité de gouverner valablement
vous vouz dire qu'il avait plus toutes
ses facultés vraiment ou quoi il était
lucide 2 heur par jour et pendant ces 2
heures disaient ces ministres en privé
il prenaient des des des décisions tout
à fait arbitraires euh qui n'allaient
pas tout à fait dans le sens des
intérêts de la Tunisie et tout le monde
je dois dire se lamenter en Tunisie je
parle des gens qui étaient des c'est
c'estesutenant les plus fidèles je ne
parle pas de la population alors dans la
population la situation euh était assez
tendue quand je suis arrivé et elle
s'est rapidement dégradée parce que
quelques semaines après la grande
centrale ouvrière laugtt avait été mise
en la loi la les principaux dirigeants
arrêtés et même les locaux de la
centrale ouvrière avaient été saccagés
par des hommes de main du
gouvernement puis la presse a été
bayonnée la presse officielle utilisait
la la langue de bois les partis
politiques étaient tous plus ou moins
interdits et en tout cas Bayonnais ne
pouvait pas s'exprimer donc il fallait
que quelque chose change et et et déjà
avait commencé les manifestations des
rues oui des revendications je dirais
économique parce que les salaires
avaient été bloqués depuis TR depuis 3 4
ans et les prix avaient avaient monté
énormément il y a eu alors des
manifestations populaires non pas
islamiques populaires et à l'université
c'était l'agitation permanente
l'université était facilement fermé
c'est pas moi les tr/4 de l'année alors
c'était selon vous c'est simplement
l'état sénil de bourgiba qui
occasionnait ces ces problèmes et ces
événements en Tunisie l'état sénil à mon
avis est un facteur aggravant parce que
comme je viens de vous le dire la
situation intérieure économique et
politique
était catastrophique alors quand vous
avez un chef d'État qui n'est pas
capable capable de gouverner cette
situation cette situation
catastrophique pouvait d'ailleurs
c'était mon opinion déjà dès l'époque
tourner court à l'époque vous
rappelez-vous on parlait de la
prébourgibisme la prébourguisie c'était
après la mort du président et j'étais
arrivé à la conclusion très rapidement
qu'il fallait s'attendre à des
événements graves avant la mort de
bourgiba et malheureusement les choses
sont passées ainsi alors dernière
question er houlot monsieur Benali on le
connaît mal c'est un ancien militaire
est-ce que ça va changer les choses
quant à la ligne politique par rapport
aux alliances traditionnelles de la
Tunisie et par rapport par exemple aux
problèmes
intégristes je crois qu' on peut dire
deux choses à ce propos d'abord le
problème intégriste a peut-être été créé
un peu artificiellement euh le mouvement
intégriste n'est pas majoritaire en
Tunisie mais il a subi une telle
répression que ça a suscité beaucoup de
sympathie dans l'opinion il est probable
à mon avis que le nouveau le nouveau
président de de Tunisie rétablira les
toutes les libertés publiques y compris
celles du mouvement islamiste le
mouvement islamiste affirme d'e manière
catégorique il est prêt à je à jouer le
jeu démocratique je pense que le nouveau
président que je connais assez bien leur
donnera la chance de pouvoir s'intégrer
dans la vie politique tunisienne la
deuxième chose qu'il faut dire en
réponse à votre question je ne m'attends
pas à des
changements immenses ou ou radicaux
parce que tous les hommes qui sont au
pouvoir aujourd'hui sont des hommes de
Monsieur BBA qui étaient déjà dans le
système et tout dépend des réformes qui
vont qui vont prendre et surtout de la
rapidité parce que il y a sûrement dans
dans dans l'opinion tunisienne une
grande attente de changement de
changement merci voilà pour ce premier
commentaire on en termine avec ces
changements en Tunisie par l'évocation
de l'histoire en effet c'est un
personnage historique qui quitte ainsi
la scène politique ce matin Habib
bourgiba est avec le président ivoirien
au fouet de boigi l'un des deux derniers
chefs d'État du continent africain ayant
accédé à la tête de leur pays depuis
l'émancipation accordée par la France
c'est en 1956 en effet que la Tunisie
protectorat français devient
indépendante son premier président
s'appelle Habib bourgiba Jérôme
BNY 3 juin 1955 triomphe à Tunis pour le
héros de l'indépendance Habib bourgiba
acclamé par 1 million de Tunisiens à son
retour d'exil un an plus tard le
combattant suprême comme l'ont appelé
ses camarade prend le pouvoir du nouvel
État tunisien indépendant dont il se
nomme président à vie après avoir déposé
le mon fin politicien usant de ses dons
de comédien et surtout de tribun
bourgiba commence par s'attaquer au
sousdéveloppement il interdit la
polygamie émancipe la femme et scolarise
le
[Applaudissements]
pays je dispose d'un pouvoir absolu je
vous assure que ce pouvoir absolu est
accepté par le peuple n'estce pas comme
le pouvoir d'un
père les enfants quand il voi pas de la
peur devant le chef de l'État ils
viennent pour
m'embrasser libéral le père de la
Tunisie n'hésite pas pourtant à mettre
en prison ses adversaires politiques il
doit faire face à une agitation sociale
qui menace plusieurs fois son régime en
janvier 1984 les émeutes déclenchés par
une ha subite du pain sont sévèrement
réprimés le combattant suprême part en
guerre contre tout ce qu'il considèent
comme des obstacles entre le peuple et
lui en 85 les partis de l'opposition
renoncent à des éle qu' considère comme
trué les syndicats sont neutralisés à
l'extérieur bourgiba entretient le
dialogue avec les pays occidentaux
notamment la France ainsi qu'avec le
monde arabe mais au début de l'année 87
il r les relations diplomatiques avec
l'Iran prenant pour prétexte
l'arrestation de terroristes tunisiens à
Paris son dernier combat il l'a engagé
cet été contre le mouvement islamiste
afin d'assurer une succession
laïque voilà pour le dossier Tunis est
ce que l'on pouvait en dire ce midi 70e
anniversaire de la révolution
bolchevique célébrée ce matin à Moscou
par le traditionnel défilé sur la place
rouge au centre de la tribune Michael
Gorbatchev invité d'honneur cette année
fidèle Castro Gil
Rabine un défilé traditionnel ouvert par
cette rétrospective insolite des soldats
habillés comme l'était en 1917 les
gardes Rouses de Trotski les gardes
Rouses de la révolution bolchevique ces
cavaliers ce sont les Sabres du maréchal
boudeni et ses marins ceux du croiseur
Aurora qui le 7 novembre 1917 avait
ouvert le feu sur le Palais d'Hiver à
pétrograde clou du défilé ces
mitrailleuses d'époque tiré par une
Troya de trois chevaux le grandiose de
cette parade cache mal le malaise actuel
de l'Armée rouge une armée dont tous les
chefs ont été changés en moins d'un an
une armée qui a du mal à envisager
l'aprèssommet rigan gorbatcheev traité
de désarmement nucléaire qu'ils vont
signer dans un mois jour pour jour à
Washington une armée enfin dont la
neutralité politique et moins que jamais
garanti tous les observateurs
occidentaux ont noté que les
euromissiles option zéro oblige étaient
absent de ce défilé un défilé dont on
dit qu'il pourrait être le
dernier en France le le weekend accorde
un peu de répis aux affaires en cours
d'abord l'affaire ler les ventes d'armes
clandestines à l'Iran dans une interview
à Canal plus le Premier ministre Jacques
Chirac calme le jeu attention aux
polémiques dont tout le monde serur
moindri dit-il et l'Hôtel Matignon a
fait savoir dans un communiqué que le
premier ministre n'avait pas l'intention
d'interpeller le président de la
République sur ce dossier bien que
plusieurs membres de sa majorité l'ai
réclamé l'affaire Michel Droit
l'écrivain membre de la CNCL a obtenu
que le juge d'instruction qui l'avait
inculpé de forfaiture pour favoritisme à
l'égard d'une radio locale voit
provisoirement son instruction suspendue
cette décision extrêmement rapide de la
Cour de cassation est rare dans les
anales ce qui ne manque pas de créer un
certain émoi dans les syndicats de
magistrat notamment les plus plus engagé
politiquement Patrice
vel affaire droit Michel contre Grelier
Claude un juge d'instruction et son
inculpé dans un contexte très
particulier celui de la Cour de
cassation hier soir la décision tombe
suspension provisoire de l'instruction
le juge Grelier se voit retirer tout
pouvoir d'instruire le dossier CNCL la
cour statuera sur le fond le 10 décembre
prochain une situation peu fréquente une
décision prise avec une rapidité
inhabituelle et moi chez les juges
d'instruction pour C c'est
l'indépendance de la justice qui est en
cause nous craignons malheureusement que
cette décision ne soit le premier pas
d'un daisissement véritable du juge
Grelier dans cette affaire et nous
posons la question de savoir quel a été
le rôle de Monsieur ivroca membre de la
CNCL et par ailleurs avocat général près
de la Cour de cassation dans cette
décision en tout état de cause cette
décision reflète une main mise du
pouvoir politique sur la justice main
mise qui existe depuis plusieurs mois
qui s'est révélé au travers de l'affaire
du carrefour du développement qui s'est
révélé au travers de l'affaire Lucher
dans ces conditions la justice ne peut
absolument plus jouer son rôle car la
justice n'est plus indépendante du
pouvoir
politique pas de réaction pour le moment
des autres syndicats l'association des
magistrats instructeurs qui regroupe 50
% de la profession devrait prendre
position en début de semaine prochaine
donc ce dossier est loin d'être clos
jugement maintenant à papté en Polynésie
française 15 jours après les violentes
manifestations dans le centre de la
ville souvenez-vous se Haïtiens qui
étaient accusés de pillage et de vol ont
été condamnés à des peines de prison
allant de 15 jours à deux en feres les
leaders syndicaux des dockers qui sont
eux aussi arrêtés seront jugés
ultérieurement puis en
Nouvelle-Calédonie à la suite de la mort
d'un jeune mélanésien abattu par des
gendarmes au cours d'une opération de
police la gendarmerie fait savoir que
les sommations d'usage avaient été
effectué quant à Monsieur jjibou le
leader des indépendantistes il estime
lui pour sa part que la chasse au Canac
est tout ouvert je le cite et puis cette
dépêche avant de passer au sport cette
fois-ci le problème est bien réglé à
l'Unesco c'est bien l'espagnol fredéic
mayor qui a été élu aujourd'hui ce matin
officiellement Directeur général de
l'UNESCO nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir sur cette information le sport
maintenant donc avec le tennis bien
entendu et la qualification d'Henry
Lecomte pour les demi-finales de l'Open
de Paris il rencontre cet après-midi
team Mayot en en demi-finale donc et en
quart de finale il avait battu
l'Australien cas très belle victoire
Olivier Henri lecte s'est payé cash hier
soir à Bercy le numéro 1 français a
éliminé l'Australien à l'issue d'un
match de 3h 13 minut en 37 le compte et
Cash ont offert au 14000 spectateurs une
splendide partie après avoir remporté le
premier set 64 le Français a laissé
échapper TR balles de match au cours du
2e set gagné par cash au taillebreak 119
mais bien en jambe rapide agressif
le Français s'est repris pour s'imposer
dans le 3e set 6-3 il s'est ainsi
qualifié pour les demi-finales où il
affrontera cet après-midi l'Américain
Mayot vainqueur de l'Israélien monsdorf
64 62 reste à savoir maintenant si le
compte aura récupérer de ses efforts
pour rencontrer team Mayot très en forme
actuellement comme le prouve sa victoire
au tournoi de
Toulouse débarrassé de ses ennuis de
santé le compte a retrouvé confiance en
ses moyens l'arrivée de fibac comme
entraîneur n'est sans doute pas
étrangère à ce retour au premier plan du
français voilà en direct donc cet
après-midi sur Antenne 2 bien sûr avec
l'autre demi-finale Brad Gilbert contre
le Hollandais sheapers et on va prendre
les nouvelles de la météo pour terminer
et à Bercy là aussi tout à fait tout à
fait je suis dans les coulisses de Bercy
dans le hameau où sont reçus les invités
de cette de cette deème open de Paris
alors pour vous annoncer un changement
du temps pour ce weekend en effet une
nouvelle perturbation va à arrivé sur le
Sud-Ouest donc déjà des nuages cet
après-midi sur le nord et bien des
brouillards qui lorsqu'ils voudront bien
se lever et bien laisseront place au
soleil mais un soleil timide toutefois
en revanche un soleil plus vaillant du
longue d'ocousillon aux Alpes Maritimes
en passant sur la Corse 20° ajxo
seulement 6° à Paris alors demain
progression des nuages sur le Sud-Ouest
qui donneront des pluies modérées sur
Laquitaine et sur les piréné sur le nord
nord-ouest de la grisaille avec un
soleil un brouillard qui sera lent très
lent à ce ip en revanche du grand soleil
surt le flanc Est et puis à signaler que
demain les températures s'lèveront un
tout petit
peu merci José je vous souhaite à tous
un bon tennis sur Antenne 2 cet
après-midi on se retrouve ce soir à 20h
au revoir bon après-midi à tout à
[Musique]
l'heure